wie kann man sich dann immer für die
falsche spur entscheiden
auto
du bräuchte führerschein auffrischung
die macht monatlich einfach
wie viele gefahren werden sondern mit
den letzten 48 stunden gemacht
ich habe nein ich war gut ich kann doch
nichts dafür wenn einfach jemand drüber
fährt
es ist grün straße heißt einfach
fressgasse
die sache ist dass der liebe tätowierer
hat mir auch ein talent gesehen und
meinte dass mich ja auch mal zeit nicht
artikulieren setzen sollte deswegen hat
sich ja wohnen und ganz ernst
herausgesucht die sich einfallsreich und
zwar
[Musik]
ich glaube ich ein bisschen schiss
ehrlich gesagt da ich das ist mir jetzt
mit dem stift gesticktes zu beachten die
wohl stehen keine fordern
was für eine stimme auf einmal ist
darauf zu bekommen ich bin auch
erst mal so schlecht ich war damals 1844
entscheiden damit du mich kennen habe
machen kannst ja
das stimmt so wenig vertrauen einmal
[Musik]
aussehen ich glaube ich bin durch
ich wollte ihm nicht wehtun
ich muss los jetzt auch
noch mal alles in saint marc macht
studieren
wie nirgendwo sonst
das ist vom
segen zunahme ist was es war sowieso
dass meine farbe das meinst du wieder
spritzt
nadelstich stunden oder tage kostenlos
[Musik]
es gibt es jetzt gekostet bei dir was
das bei mir gekostet hätte
verkaufen können bist du zufrieden mit
der meisterwerke
erlöse sind zufrieden
bist reich du
kannst wir waren jetzt gerade auf jeden
fall die ganze
rest mich erstmal nicht
wir sind im podcast studio angekommen
so sieht das studie die auf jeden fall
aus wir haben hier vorne eine so geile
backsteinwand mit dem dicken hoss zahlen
wir haben hier verschiedene bilder wohin
die 19 uhr sandra drauf ist hier sitzt
sie
haben auch keine richtigen tisch sondern
werden einfach reist auch skizzen
genommen wir haben überall kühl stehen
mit kissen ist die bahn darf sandy und
wir nehmen jetzt auf
ja darf mich jetzt wissen
podcast folge ist vorbei ich fasse die
restlichen punkte nicht an
mittlerweile führt übrigens einfach eine
brieffreundschaft mit den verletzten ist
ein brief an meine tür gelegt haben denn
die haben jetzt wieder was vor die tür
gelegt danke euch wir werden alles gute
nachträglich an der stelle wie hat sich
eine neue tasche gekauft und diese
tasche ist so klein dass nicht nur das
portemonnaie reinpasst das ist die auch
mit abstand hässlichste tasche die ich
je gesehen habe da fragt sich die ganze
zeit wie dieses ding heißt es macht wie
willst du das nennen was dem stuhl
ja wenn ich jetzt nicht am schreibtisch
drehstuhl
aber macht keinen sinn der kann sich
nicht nur trainieren auch rollen
rollstuhl macht auch keinen sinn
rollstuhl ist das foto drinsitzen sich
voran rolf wolltest du
leute kommentiert man bitte wie das
heißt also wie heißt ein stuhl mit
rollen und zum drehen wenn ich nicht am
schreibtisch sitzen
wir erfinden neue wörter
goethe
ich war grad im gym und habe nach dem
training meine mama angerufen bei mir
ein bisschen schwindlig war sie hat mir
daraufhin geantwortet trinkt auch mal
ein bisschen was
das ist genauso wie wenn du mir sagst
sein handy ist kaputt und ich sagte dann
macht's mal an und aus
bringt auch nichts was man eigentlich
eine bestimmte gewichtsklasse erreicht
haben um im fitnessstudio jim zu nennen
stabile haare übrigens luca als ich
vorhin trainiert habe hatte ich auch
übrigens keine kopfhörer dabei
das heißt ich musste die ganze zeit
gegen welchen leuten bei dem bullshit zu
hören aus ein richtiges live programms
über dich gerade berichtet letzte woche
schon erzählt dass ich so einen vertrag
abgeschlossen habt weil ich ja nur 14
wochen in hamburg bin noch für den
zeitraum trainieren will blablabla doch
scheißegal dabei sollte gar nicht gehen
die sache ist nur dass sich dort in der
vornamen spalte meinen vor und
zweitnamen eingegeben hat
und jetzt bin ich heute abgecheckt aus
dem gym und die kassiererin da vorne an
der rezeption sagt einfach tschüss luca
di leo
warum hat man zweiter haben ich verstehe
diese sind nicht ich weiß halt das ist
früher bei mir so war dass der name luca
zumindest als ich geboren wurde im jahr
nicht eindeutig ein männer name war
deswegen brauchte ich ein zweiter
[Musik]
ich brauche auf jeden fall einen zweiten
namen der eindeutig zeigt dass ich ein
junge will
frag mich was ich für ein geschlecht
dann sage ich diesen brüchen zweiten
namen ich hasse meinen zweiten die
absolute höhe wäre es noch gewesen wenn
meine eltern als zweitnamen nicht thilo
sondern kino genommen hätten das ist
nämlich der hier von des wochenendes
das traurige ist dass ich leider genauso
früher aussah kann meine freude mit
lernen ihre sprache nachrichten kurz
halten
das ist die nachricht und kein podcast
welchen podcast
ich habe
gerne mal aufgefallen dass leute mit
glatze voll häufig in bad hamm
ich wegziehen die verschoben
das geht 04 jetzt brauche ich einfach
falsch rum erst habe ich ganz hamburg
für dieses teil gehälter dann habe ich
besser aus glas weil sie selber den
start und jetzt trage ich auch mal was
neues mit ner
ich warten jetzt mal ab war nämlich den
ganzen tag lang shoppen weil es den
ganzen tag lang shoppen
chillige belichtung dass die abweichung
gehalten ja das ist ein neuer trend
[Musik]